انتخابات مبكره في شبه جزيره القرم هناك
ما هو الحال في المناطق الاوكرانيه الاخرى
التي ضمتها موسكو تم اجراء انتخابات محليه
قبل اسبوع من موعدها منذ عام 2014 اصبح
السكان يحملون جوازات سفر روسيه لذا يتعين
عليهم اختيار رؤساء البلديات ورؤساء
الاقاليم ونوابهم المستقبلي
بواجبي كمواطن لقد كنا ننتظر هذا منذ مده
فهو مهم بالنسبه الينا
جئت للتصويت للاشخاص الذين سيساعدوننا في
ان نصبح جزءا من روسيا الى الابد
بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا فان الكريم يحاول
تعزيز قبضته على الاراضي المحتله بشكل غير
قانوني
اذا نظرنا الى قائمه المرشحين على سبيل
المثال المرشحي حزب روسيا المتحده فبالكاد
28 من اصل 60 هم من السكان الاصليين
كما هو الحال في الدنيا فان الانتخابات
نظمت باحكام اذ اقامت روسيا مراكز اقتراع
بالقرب من خطوط المواجهه واخرى متنقله
للجنود والاشخاص المعزولين اما اولئك
الذين يبعدون عن مناطقس فان لديهم امكانيه
التصويت في المكاتب الموجوده في جميع
المناطق الروسيه
تصويت لانهاء الحرب والعيش بشكل افضل
والتمكن من العوده الى دياري تحضر كييف من
ان هذه الانتخابات غير قانونيه ومن ان
الاسماء المدرجه في القوائم الانتخابيه
ستتعرض لخطر التجنيد